the new hitman makes its debut as the
first episode of a complete story it's
where you train as agent 47 during his
induction into the international
contract agency to familiarize yourself
with the flow of missions it's also
where you infiltrate a well-attended
fashion show 20 years later
to assassinate targets surrounded by
layers of security there are multiple
ways to slip in and out of the missions
three secure locations and many means to
complete your objectives blending great
amounts of replayability for the curious
and creative hitman sandboxes are
intricately woven offering an abundance
of decision-making opportunities that
can drastically change your approach
towards a mission and the execution of
objectives do you infiltrate and choke
your target with a wire or slip poison
into their favorite cocktail these are
two of many possible tactics that you
can employ more than objects are people
in an environment it's hit man's UI
settings that hold the most power over
your experience though you can take
advantage of systems the likes of which
allow agent 47 to see through walls that
can make your job easier you may also
choose to disable all assist options and
immerse yourself in the challenge at
hand in a sea of hundreds surrounded by
potential threats agent 47s missions can
be daunting assignments that test your
ability to improvise under smothering
scrutiny once you complete your first
run-through hit man's three missions
your job isn't quite finished escalation
missions appear introducing new
objectives with constraints that dictate
new targets what equipment you have to
use and even what type of disguise you
have to wear during a kill you can also
create your own contracts with full
control over the APRA mentioned
conditions and objectives you simply
need to enter a location mark targets
take them out and successfully escape
there's no denying that repeatedly
revisiting the same locations wears on
your enthusiasm but escalation missions
and contracts Steve this feeling off for
a while because hitman is episodic at
the moment you don't have the chance to
move through a campaign and distance
yourself from a mission and that can't
be helped of course there's a lot to do
if you're looking for new opportunities
but after your first run-through a
mission the feeling of immersion fades
as you transition into full-on puzzle
solving mode as you poked and prodded
hit man looking for new ways to complete
missions and take advantage of your
options you also start to notice gaps in
logic that allow you to circumvent AI
reaching from behind an enemy to grab
something on a table in front of them
won't necessarily get their attention as
long as you're close enough to trigger a
button prompt without passing through
their field of view your
clear you can also act like a total
oddball bumping into important people or
crouching suspiciously near them without
triggering any concern
hitman presents itself as a stealth game
that can be as hardcore as you want it
to be but it's AI fails to connect all
the dots on a semi-regular basis should
I be able to exit a mission after
gunning down people in a packed party
you wouldn't think so but somehow the
guards Manning the exit don't always get
the memo when there's a madman on the
loose you can choose to ignore these
moments or use them to your advantage
but you can't dismiss how they detract
from hit man's proposed tension then
again hitman is sometimes designed to
make you laugh you really have to do
this
All Things Considered we're putting a
pasty-faced egg head inside a Mach 3
fighter jet yeah I kind of think we do
as you go about your business on a
mission non-threatening NPCs comment on
your seemingly benign but strange
behavior they whine about their jobs and
you engage with them in disguise there
is a definite contrast between hit man's
gameplay in its story which is doled out
in mysterious cutscenes that feature
stone-cold antagonists it man feels at
odds with itself on occasion but there's
no question that missions are the star
of the show not the story at least for
now hit man's opening act isn't
groundbreaking but the host of tiny
problems lending in a dated feel however
it's a veritable playground that will
delight you with its open-ended design
comical NPCs and contract creation tools
these qualities and the flexibility to
be as hardcore or laid-back as you want
to be are much appreciated even if they
don't disguise hit man's lesser
qualities huh Wow
never knew this stuff was so complicated
what's this one for
yeah that's a firework
touch it if I were you Java cops
expecting a heads-up before trigger the
display so you watch
you